una de las gráficas que se muestra a
continuación tiene una fuerte relación
no lineal con la siguiente propiedad
conforme x aumenta de 0.5 y disminuye 18
a 2 y se queda estancada ahí hasta el
final que gráfica coincide con la
descripción mencionada
veamos tenemos estas cuatro gráficas y
nos dicen que es una fuerte relación no
lineal entonces tendremos que ver algo
que no podamos modelar con una línea en
esta primera gráfica vemos que estos
datos sin duda nos podemos modelar con
una línea aquí hay una relación lineal y
de hecho es una relación lineal negativa
porque conforme x aumenta y disminuye la
segunda gráfica bueno vemos que aquí
conforme x va aumentando hasta este
punto se va disminuyendo y luego se
queda estable lo mismo o algo similar
está ocurriendo la gráfica 3 y también
en la 4 de estos 3 que son más o menos
las que cumplen con una restricción que
nos ponen aquí que es que conforme x
aumenta y disminuye y se queda estancada
y hasta el final vamos a analizar bien
esta restricción
aumenta de 0.5 y disminuye de 18 a 2 en
este caso cuando x es cero llenará nos
llega hasta 10 esta no me sirve la
gráfica 3 cuando x es igual a 0 aquí
tengo y equivale 18 y cuando x es igual
a punto 5 que disminuye de 18 a 2
entonces está de 18 a 2 cuando x avanza
este rango este cuadrito de acá está si
tiene esa tendencia y después se queda
en este mismo valor y ya no cambia en
cambio la gráfica 4 vemos que cuando x
es 0 está en 18 los valores de james
pero ésta lleva a disminuir hasta 10 no
hasta 2 como nos indican aquí en la
restricción por lo tanto esta no es
nuestra respuesta es la gráfica atrás
comprobemos lo en efecto